happy 4/20 [ __ ] Mike so happy
for to any [ __ ]
what's going on yo we got a message from
Charles Xavier
smalls Charlie banned the head of full
moon features and they released a video
that we're like okay when 4/20 comes
around that's an evil bong six six six
woo before we go into this trait what no
noise all day no no okay before we go
into this trailer we recently launched
the patreon so we want her to give a
shout out to some like people dicks
bunch of dicks outside thank you know so
many people donated and you guys have
been like yeah credibly sweet oh my it's
God it's been pretty old I almost cried
when I saw like how many people donated
seriously it was very we wanted to start
doing some of the reward stuff patron of
the day shout out patron of the day man
paid so he could get the shoutout Dylan
font Thomas there's a little photo of
Dylan font Thomas real on Thomas you
know what I should pull up Dylan font
Thomas so you know what he looks like
sexy man said I include your photo you
look like John Bailey looks exactly like
John it is a sexy job if you don't know
John bit you look like a little jumpy to
slim down a lot now so Bailey slim down
walk even sexier now I was gonna say
when I got slimmer John Bailey but John
Bailey you guys yeah
John Bailey's sexy so I'm saying you're
sexy if congratulations you were in sexy
oh my god I like that Jersey yeah
alright let's finally watch this trailer
yes due to the reduction already this is
to the reduction this is for you Charlie
do love
[Music]
[Music]
hell yeah oh my god
ginger wait oh no this is a crossover
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I am bezel bud there's some funny-ass
[ __ ]
yeah I've never know it does look like
the perfect for 20 mm I've never heard
of full moon what's full moon they
produced these like low-budget kind of
zany
you know horror and sci-fi movies and
you've seen some of them yeah I've seen
a couple of them that was something
special kind of like they throw they
throw trauma and full moons names are
running in the same it feels like a
sketch out of like Mystery Science
Theater yeah they're always kind of zine
I'm wondering if this is a crossover
because Gary Busey plays Gingerdead man
oh dude probably a ginger you know like
a pot cookie dude you're dead you seem
excited I just think this is funny it's
been a while since I've seen a trailer
like this and it just kind of warmed my
heart oh yeah this trailer look great
I'm not gonna judge this like ah sets
like yeah it's a low-budget like oh no
it's the most evil bomb yeah it's
supposed to I wouldn't want it any other
way if it was like a serious trailer
with this goofy gimmick I don't think I
would have enjoyed it as much yeah I
loved that it felt like out of them a
90's TV ship or 80s probably earlier
this isn't my favorite kind of horror
but I do like every now and again one of
these is so much fun ginger weed yeah oh
dude that's so I'm gonna be for
Halloween yeah yeah ginger would do that
you do well with that you can be bezel
buddy the whole like Satan stuff was
stupid until he said I'm bezel buddy oh
yeah yeah these movies are full of that
[ __ ] they're totally wacky and they know
what what fun they're having and he said
this is on Hulu now it's premiering on
Hulu and Amazon guys it's already nice
it's so ready yeah jump on it jump on it
thanks Charles
yeah thanks that was just I don't know I
like the message came in and I just kind
of nerd it hey dinner I didn't know what
was going on
or I will do what you want well happy
4/20 or powdered again to Dylan hey
subscribe to the reject channel
subscribe to us reasons to Jerry and is
the Schmo down MVP of the free-for-all
and he is also the social media manager
of blow my house calm the real rejects
and yes we did launch a patreon recently
we actually we were like brainstorming a
lot for all the things we want to do on
patreon yeah though there might be some
exclusive audio